and now we are in the period of time
where a lot of people are throwing at
you a lot of stones by saying that's not
going to work little discipline you do
little things with a lot of discipline
you do a lot of things oh you know you
have a hit stop the media right think
about it is how much profit are you
making from this car if you are sure
from the beginning gonna hit all your
targets that mean your target are
conservative don't plan too much I does
work if you don't start mapping and
establishing milestone you know you're
never going to be getting there you need
to have your own strength you need to
have your own believes make your own
analysis from time to time making quick
decision it's going to hurt the
execution of the dish year we can treat
people in the 21st century if somehow
you don't assume the consequence of your
ass he's a French Lebanese Brazilian
businessman he's currently the chairman
and CEO of france-based Renault and
Japanese based Nissan in 2003 fortune
named him one of the 10 most powerful
people in business outside the US he's
Carlos gone and here's my take on his
top 10 rules for success you have to
have a vision this vision has to be
based on understanding about the
dynamics of the market globally and then
you have to pursue this vision no matter
what you have to build motivation inside
your company this is easy because you're
saying okay we want to be leader in
technology that is meaningful for the
consumer and although he some people all
the Renault people are binding to it
then we need to come to the consumer and
tell him you know tell the consumer
that's a great product which is
affordable and on top of this is going
to allow you to drive without the guilt
of the melting of the icebergs and the
change of seasons and the temperature
etc I think it's going to be very
powerful but again before it starts
there is always a doubt and now we are
in the period of time where a lot of
people are throwing at you a lot of
stones by saying that's not going to
work and then you have a lot of comments
from competitors saying you know you're
too much bullish is not going to well
obviously what you want competitors to
say is this is in the right direction
I'd say ok
is in the right direction and what is
your car well I have no extra car so
what's what's the situation so going on
perhaps a decade of running
simultaneously to two global companies
how do you get the stamina to keep going
and to stay fit you know personally and
mentally and physically well you know
somebody said with a little discipline
you do little things with a lot of
discipline you do a lot of things and we
start to discipline there is nothing
which you cannot do it requires a lot of
discipline I mean obviously because
you're going to move from one world to
the other from one culture to the other
from two completely different company
yeah jet LAG's organization people are
expecting you when you come down from a
plane after 14 hours flight to be fresh
and ready for them but they're not
expecting the CEO to come and say oh my
god is jet lag he cannot answer a
question they want you to be on the go
all the time so this requires a lot of
discipline you have to organize yourself
if you know you're going to do this job
and you accept the job you have to
organize yourself in order to do it it's
tough but there is a solution there is
there is a solution for it but it
requires a lot of choices personal
choices there are a lot of things you
cannot do you know there are a lot of
things you can do but you're going to do
them within a certain order but
particularly with a lot with the loss of
discipline are you going to be able to
make products who are hits okay first
question after one two years we start to
turn you the product line up we had some
hits some of them are major how do you
know you have a hit stop the media
writing about it is how much profit are
you making from this car that's the way
you know you know you'd be happy the
350z is a hit the Murano is a hit these
are some of the most profitable cars we
have ever had that's a way that mean
it's not only that the media saying this
is a great car and people are buying it
because you can have a great car people
buying it and not make one nickel in it
it doesn't mean that it's a project it's
a hit well the real hit is the product
has to be successful but at the same
time you need to sell as much as you you
think the potential is and make money
out of it that's the
a demonstration demonstration of it you
had pretty ambitious sales targets are
you going to be able to hit those you
never know until the last minute you
know the objective of when you make a
long-term plan is not to make sure from
the beginning that you're going to hit
them because if you are through from the
beginning going to hit all your targets
that mean your target are conservative
that's the only way you can be sure so
you want to maintain a certain stretched
inside the company and being innovative
and creative and finding new products
and new solutions in order to hit the
target
so it's risky but that's the price to
pay for development don't plan too much
I does work for me didn't work frankly
don't plan too much your carrier because
what you want to be facing in life is
probably more powerful and much bigger
than you ever imagined so if you're
following your plan you may miss a lot
of opportunity coming on the side but
you don't even look at them but say oh I
need to continue on my plan okay
even though on the side you're going to
a huge opportunity coming you don't look
at them so don't plan too much or be
flexible on the planning you're going to
have a lot of ordering particularly in
the period we're getting in 2010 2020 I
think gonna be a lot of transformation
coming and they're going to be a lot of
opportunity so be flexible I think you
famously said strategy is 5% of the
answer and execution is 95% so so what
does that mean and how did you actually
what did you do differently but you know
the 5% yeah I said yeah 5% of the
challenge is a strategy 95% of the
execution this I said it as CEO of
Nissan I said it also a CEO Freneau and
I said it as deputy CEO of Renault when
I said the first time it was mainly in
France and I was to my - to the top
management of Renault in France because
there was a tendency in the company to
spend too much time on strategy and
leave the execution for other people and
this is where I said yeah strategies
fine is very important but it's only 5%
if you don't go to execution after this
the delivery and the performance of the
company is going to be very weak I
really I really believe it now it
doesn't mean strategy's not important
but when you establish north and you
know exactly where north is for the
company
you've done something very important
because you're giving the direction but
if you don't start moving north if you
don't start mapping and establishing
milestone you know you're never going to
be getting there you're never going to
be getting there you say nobody likes
people who are different usually we like
to go you know you can go out with males
engineers from the same school same
education speaking in the same language
it's a much more comfortable the problem
is when we are all alike we don't learn
anything it's comfortable but we don't
learn now when you go with somebody who
is completely different from the
different background it's more difficult
but you're going to learn a lot of
things maybe you can learn a language
different ways of looking at things etc
diversity is a wealth but diversity has
to be managed and managing the cross
culture is something which is going to
be at the same time very hard but can
generate a lot of potential don't work
for recognition it's an illusion
somebody was saying you know if you want
recognition buy yourself a dog gimme
don't work for recognition you're gonna
be disappointed you're gonna be
disappointed work for yourself obviously
work for no matter what are your
objective if you want to become wealthy
if you wanna you know I mean work for
yourself
work for it so I'm not saying that we
need to be a go centuries that are
looking no but but I think do not put
too much emphasis on the outside what
the outside is going to be bring you
because you're going to be disappointed
you're going to be disappointed and I
want to tell you why why it's very
important to hold this line because
because when when you'll have to make
hard decisions and probably some of you
will have in the future you're going to
be long do not think that this is a team
it's not true at the end of the day the
guy is going to make the ultimate
decision is one and this guy is going to
do it alone and he's going to do it
based on his own value and his own
beliefs and his own analysis transmitted
by his team wherever every but at the
end of the day he or she is doing the
decision and when you carry the decision
you're going to be bombarded no matter
so if you're looking for an outside
recognition is going to melt you down
you're say oh my god that means it's not
working everybody no no you need to have
your own strength you need to have your
own believes make your own analysis and
carry and carry the decision one of the
thing I learned particularly in Japan
that from time to time making quick
decision is going to hurt the execution
of the decision because I do what you
want when you make a decision what you
want you want to transform reality you
don't want to make a decision for the
sake of making a decision you make a
decision because you want something to
change so your goal is the thing changed
that's your goal so now the question is
when should you make the decision in
order to make sure that this thing has
changed in the fastest period of time so
from time to time you have to wait to
make the decision because you're
preparing people to execute from time to
time you need to make the decision very
early from time to time a little bit
late but when I say this is eveness mean
capacity to take the decision at the
appropriate time because at the end of
the day what you need is reality changes
that's that's your goal how can you ask
new people whoever they are to do
efforts to go the extra mile if somehow
you don't commit to the results it's
impossible if people don't see that you
are working as hard as I do if you have
too much you have been at the top level
at all the level of the company you have
too much as much as risk as I do then
I'm going to follow they are not going
to follow so commitment is a very
important part of you know the
management style of the lines because in
a certain way this is one way to stretch
the organization and stretch people by
putting the challenge very clearly on
the table and no buts and ifs and what
you have to dedicate everything in order
to make the plan a success you're not
going to spend your time explaining why
it was not successful okay
and that's a big difference between the
Rono plan and all the other plan which
were announced for the two weeks before
and after where there was no commitment
okay if I come and see you and say you
buy the
way I'm going to do my best I'm going to
reduce cost and then you need six
thousand jobs and shut down three plants
and we're going to shut down this
operation and we're going to stop this
and that and that and you know if it
doesn't work we'll come back next year
with another plan you know if I am
working in the company
I say hey first my job is going to be
limited what's going to happen
I'm worried yeah so I'm not going to
give a hand to this guy because I don't
know on top of this what's going to
happen if it's if it's not successful is
that committed so this from the other
side people say you taking commitment
you're not smart because if you don't
fulfill the commitment it's a bad
consequence for you yes that's it we are
at the heart of this issue you have at
the heart of issue we can't manage in
the 21st century yeah we can treat
people in the 21st century if somehow
you don't assume the consequence of your
ads and the consequence of your ads
cannot be on the alidium state no from
time to time it's you have a vision you
have the plan you have a strategy we
have objective you're asking people to
work day and night for them you have to
assume that person that's the management
of the 21st century that's it and I
think the strength of the Nissan plans
and the Renault plan is the fact that as
these two companies are the only one
doing these kind of things in a certain
way they're going to have a plus in
terms of performance because people are
going to feel much more motivated and
engaged whenever you have this kind of
commitment on results due to the efforts
are going to be they're going to be
they're gonna be doing
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because Eric Chico asked me
to so there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next leave it in
the comments below and I'll see what I
can do I also love to know which of
Carlos's top ten rules had the biggest
impact on you on why which is you like
the most leave it down in the comments
and I will join in the discussion thank
you so much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon
I've never seen such a thing as a boring
leader leader not nothing neither is
always somebody interesting somebody who
can connect with you very important very
important I mean so if I'm sitting with
somebody and you know after 15 minutes I
want to go to the next meeting I know
it's it's not very good so ability to
connect ability to be interested and
being interesting is also a very
important feature and you know that this
is something that you don't learn in
school or university it is something
that you developed by yourself everybody
has its own skills etc so I would say
being a listener being able to connect
with people are two absolutely basic
condition for leadership for the rest
you know efficiency ability to
communicate openness curiosity
intelligence etc that's fine
we've seen great leader who are not
smart you probably know know a lot of
them that mean they're not smart I mean
here very common no but the truth I mean
they're not smart and we've seen a lot
of people extremely smart who never
never were able to take any leadership
position so I don't think this is
something discriminating I have never
seen a leader who was boring or at least
at the beginning and may may be boring
idea you know after after five or never
and somebody who don't listen or observe
or try to see okay what's the situation
in which I am I am NOT going to
challenge you know what you're learning
at the university particularly telling
you that you know but but but when you
go and you are a foreigner going to
Japan you're going to Japan for one
reason and that's it it's turning around
the company period that's what people
expecting from you how much work what do
you do if if you have problems if you
have remorse impacted nobody cares
fix it that's it that's the message fix
it you accept the job you have to fix it
we had two main problems one the main
problem of Nissan is that we had twenty
billion dollars of depth in 1999 and no
Japanese bank and you know how flexible
Japanese Bank can be for a Japanese
I know Japanese Bank wanted to land any
money to Nissan so we were facing a cash
crunch okay this is immediate death okay
so we need to establish the trust on it
and cut that second you need to come
back to profit for 10 years Nissan had
one percent average operating profit
while Honda and Toyota we're around
seven to ten percent we had about one
percent return on invested capital where
our main competitors were at more 10%
there was something wrong you need to
establish your establish G's put it put
it right so I knew from the beginning
that what I suspected from me is fix it
fix it so when you know you need to fix
it you can say okay I'm going to make as
many changes as necessary to fix the
problem nothing more
nothing more so changing the habits if
there is no obvious result you shouldn't
do but when you know that fixing the
company is going to force you to change
some habits well then you need to say it
you need to explain why you're doing it
and particularly you need to commit to
the results because people don't like
change as long as there is no commitment
to specific results behind the change
now if you commit to specific results
they may give you the benefit of the
doubt and that's exactly what happened
in the case of Nissan oh it's careers
very important mentors very important
particularly but what they teach you
what not to do
I had many bosses in my career because I
started you know like a simple engineer
and I learned as much with the from the
managers or the leaders who are making a
lot of things which shocked me as from
the people who were inspiring me both of
them are very important why because the
guy you know who is your boss and all of
a sudden you say well you know he
doesn't communicate well I'm not
motivated etc you're learning you're
learning you're learning the basics
because you're going to always think
every time when you will be in
leadership position I don't want to
become like
X Y or Z who wear my leaders I want to
make sure that I'm interesting I'm sure
I'm associating people etc so the
mentors are positive and negatives you
have the people who are going to teach
you what are the mistakes have to do and
there are the people who are going to
inspire you by saying wow I wouldn't
have never thought about this and I
think this is very very very powerful so
you learn from both and it's it's that's
why it's very important to listen and
observe and you know some people say you
know I have the boring boss you are not
learning anything say no wrong wrong you
have a boring boss it's an opportunity
to see why is boring what are the things
you know what other things I will learn
that I will never have to do in the
future so I am not boring for the people
who are in my team if you have a great
boss from the beginning you think you're
going to think it's very easy you know
because the guy is interesting and the
objective you're being hit etc you're
not going to learn as much as when
you're going to be facing adversity from
the boss who has a lot of imperfection
obviously if you if all your bosses are
of this type is bad also because you
never know what you know what is true
north so having some of both is very is
very important I was blessed by the fact
that I had both and frankly I learned as
much from one than from the from from
the others